Android Jetpack will provide modern application architecture
Eliminate boilerplate file code and simplify complex tasks
And providing strong backward compatibility
Speed ​​up the Android development process
Architecture Guide in Jetpack
Four key areas in Android development
Supported by a series of code libraries and tools
The basis of the architecture UI behavior
Each Jetpack component can be used separately
But they still work together smoothly
On the critically acclaimed architecture component released last year
We further improved and launched Jetpack
These components help you develop
Highly testable robust application architecture
At the same time, one point for the pain points of developers
Such as life cycle management and data persistence, etc.
We have added 3 architectural components:
Paging navigation work manager
Paging component allows you to source from a local or network source
Step-by-step request-based data loading
So that the application has the ability to handle large data
This includes support for RecyclerView
The navigation component provides a framework
Can be used to build an application process that complies with the Android Design Guidelines
The app flow also has the appropriate behavior for the up and back buttons
Support deep link automatic fragment processing
Support overflow menu navigation drawer and bottom navigation
It also comes with a powerful graphical editor from Android Studio.
Allows you to visualize, design and test your app's navigation screens
Work Manager components greatly simplify the process of planning one-time or periodic asynchronous tasks
Tasks can be executed in order, at the same time, or even in more complex settings
You can easily queue tasks and provide restrictions
For example, it requires the use of non-billing network traffic or the use of toll traffic.
Perhaps the most important thing is that the Work Manager component solves the compatibility issue.
So you know what platform the user is on.
Tasks are efficiently scheduled while taking into account the health of the entire system
UI components such as animation, transition, layout, etc.
Such as ConstraintLayout, text, emoticons, clips
Also includes the TV Leanback code base
Wear UI codebase, Auto codebase, etc.
Now they are all members of Jetpack.
Behavioral components support the constantly changing Android zone
Such as notification, permission and sharing, etc.
Jetpack also added support for Slices
It allows your app to display several of its own templated parts separately
For integration with apps like Google Search and Assistant
The base component contains AppCompat
Multiple code bases for automated testing
And the new Android KTX Kotlin extension
It will let you use Kotlin for Android development.
More concise, smooth, modern
Android Jetpack is just getting started
We are developing a whole set of plans
Utility code libraries and tools
Help your Android project fly
To get started, please see developers.android.com/jetpack